[Musique]
une face à et une face b c'est au
lecteur de choisir sa porte d'entrée
pour la lecture de cette bande dessinée
voyageant lémurie est un ouvrage
construit en deux parties deux visions
que portent les artistes natacha eloi
emma carrossée ce livre c'est un livre
objet parce qu'effectivement on a
tendance à le manipuler parce qu'il faut
le manipuler en place d'une histoire une
histoire celle de sully waro et puis
celle de maka qui est celle de zarlor et
et tout est il et de russie se
retrouvent au centre avec la maintenant
un ouvrage réalisé dans le cadre des
résidences d'artistes lancé par le
département depuis 2010 est une action
qui vise à soutenir la création
artistique tout en valorisant les sites
patrimoniaux du département comme ici à
la bibliothèque départementale
la bibliothèque en soit c'est
effectivement un lieu patrimoine mais
c'est aussi l'autre un lieu de
transmission entre à la fois le public
les artistes et l'a donc ces essais pour
moi ça c'est c'est ce qu'il ya de plus
beau c'est vraiment le l'essence et puis
le si on a le plus imité de le faire
pendant ces six mois de résidence ces
deux artistes se sont inspirés des
collections patrimoniales de la
bibliothèque départementale
pour réaliser cet ouvrage qui pénètre
l'univers onirique de la lémurie
[Musique]